Senator Bernie Sanders is demanding a
minimum salary of sixty thousand dollars
for public school teachers many many
many public school teachers make well
under sixty thousand dollars
particularly in some of these states
often red states with poorer economies
and inferior educational infrastructure
I think that this is super interesting I
don't think it's going to happen as
written but the proposals Bernie is
making are very much Common Sense
proposals in many different ways not
only are we underpaying teachers based
on cost of living in many places we are
also underpaying teachers based quite
frankly on the importance of the job
that they're doing so I don't think this
particular proposal will pass as
proposed but this is very much something
we need to be talking about